quand gérard filoche ancien inspecteur
du travail bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france pas de revalorisation
générale donc après la crise et du coc
u19 c'est un nouveau coup dur pour les
fonctionnaires bien sûr ça y est nous
sommes 30 millions de salariés il y a
environ cinq millions de fonctionnaires
et leur salaire puisque le point
d'indicé est gelé a baissé d'environ 20
% 20 % depuis 25 ans et coups les plus
durs les baisses les plus durs ont été
sous les gouvernants valls hollande
macron en 2016 2017 et depuis aussi ce
qui fait que tous ceux qui ont été
indispensables pour que le pays vive
pendant la la bande émis pendant
confinement tous ceux qui avaient les
des tâches d'entretien tous ceux qui
avaient des tâches dans la fonction
hospitalière dans la fonction
territoriale et dans la fonction
publique d'état également voir ce refusé
tout tour autour on peut pas accepter
que pendant 25 ans ont perdu 20 % de
salaire et que les promesses toujours
renouvelée pour plus tard ne soit jamais
tenues le point d'indicé
c'est le principe de base de la fonction
publique vous savez les fonctionnaires
gagnent moins que dans le privé
à qualité et à un niveau égal les trois
catégories de fonctionnaires sont rares
chi dévoué pour la collectivité
ils font marcher les services publics et
ne sont pas récompensés tenir
ils sont attaqués puisque sans arrêt
c'est là dessus qu'on prend l'argent et
je ne comprends pas qu'il y ait heures
on dit qu'à 130 milliards de trouver
d'argent anciennement caché qu'ils vont
être utilisés pour l'essentiel aux chefs
d'entreprise et aux actionnaires et
alors on ne paye pas les fonctionnaires
on va évidemment modifier la donne dans
une série de de redistribution mais pas
les fonctionnaires pourtant le pays de
marcherait pas sans les fonctionnaires
promet d'ouvrir
en parallèle le dossier de la
complémentaire santé pour les fonctions
pour les fonctionnaires est ce que cela
est plutôt positif comment est-ce que
vous l'interprétez mais enfin écoutez
c'est le salaire qui compte c'est pas la
peine de nous donner des placebos des
râles des remplacements bidons des
petites soupoudrage le salaire ce
salaire savez on fait une tache un
travail on doit être payé pour son
salaire il faut pas nous faire de la
muse gogo c'est pas possible ça il faut
être clair l'augmentation des points
d'indicé le rattrapage des pertes de
pouvoir d'achat le un niveau de vie
décent et parce que c'est ça aussi qui
fera repartir l'économie tout ce qu'ils
nous disent pourquoi les gens ne peuvent
pas consommer pourquoi les gens ne
peuvent pas vivre décemment
parce que de façon générale les salaires
sont bloqués alors que les profits et
les dividendes du capital s'envole et il
suffit d'arrêter sa d'arrêter cette
distanciation qui s'opère et qui est
social entre le nombre de milliardaires
de millionnaire
les profiteurs et les actionnaires de
tout ça c'est parce qu'ils travaillent 1
c'est nous qui travaillons et quand on
travaille on nous paie pas comme il faut
dans ce contexte qu'il faut s'attendre à
une mobilisation des fans et quatre
fonctionnaires à la rentrée selon vos
âmes et elle est déjà annoncée le 17
septembre prochain
il y à une mobilisation générale parce
qu'il y a besoin de poser les questions
de santé les questions d'école des
questions de salaires les questions
d'emploi la protection contre les
licenciements faut contrôler les
licenciements faut pas déverser des
millions et des millions d'euros patron
en disant vous avez carte blanche et
vous pouvez licencier quand même tout en
augmentant ce que vous donnez à vos
actionnaires
faut arrêter ça qu'est-ce qu'il fait pas
marcher le pays c'est les salariés 88%
de la population active et salariés sans
eux rien ne fonctionne en mai alors
pourquoi ce qui est de distribuer par
messieurs macron casta et il donnait aux
autres qu'on salariés pourquoi ce n'est
pas les salariés qui reçoivent la
récompense normal et logique
de leurs efforts de leur travail je le
répète sans fonctionnaires sans salarié
plus rien ne marche et donc le 17
septembre prochain
c'est aux salariés aux fonctionnaires de
se faire entendre si l'on sait c'est une
chute sans fin
et puis nous prendrons toujours plus là
haut avec macron sa politique est
inchangée elle est brutale
elle est pliée sedan bat pour nourrir
ceux d'en haut et dont il faut arrêter
ça des salaires augmenter les salaires
merci pour votre réaction gérard filoche
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien
inspecteur du travail